the situation much different on the west
coast many there fear the tariffs could
cost jobs with prices on the rise
national correspondent William la
jeunesse is in Fontana California
tonight the cost is the biggest thing
and that's that's what's gonna hurt us
as a company if this goes through
president Trump hopes to punish China
and some others for dumping aluminum and
steel but some US steel producers say
the 25% tariff will hurt them as well if
they impose tariffs on these labs will
harm our business very bad California
Steel is the largest producer west of
the Rockies unlike mills in the Midwest
that makes steel from iron ore
California steel imports its raw
material in slabs these 25 tons slab is
heated at 2,500 degrees then it is
almost liquefied passed by rollers into
sheets of Steel those are fabricated
into coils and pipes then sold the
companies that turn finished field into
framing solar panels and more talking
about to save the American jobs right we
are American jobs Marcelo Rodriguez says
one problem is transportation importing
slabs from Mexico and Brazil by ship
cost about $20 a ton moving it by rail
from the Midwest more than $100 the
freight cost to bring from those
countries to California costs 1/4 or
150th of the freight cost from the east
coast to the west coast but the real
problem for the American steel industry
Rodriguez says is China dumping coils of
finished steel like this for $200 a ton
when the US market price is 400 we just
want fairness because we have not been
treated fairly by other countries
Rodriguez wants the president to exclude
slabs from the tariffs otherwise he says
costs will rise clients buy less forcing
layoffs killing jobs not creating this a
lot of us are looking to retire from
this company
and right now we is a bit concerned that
we don't know what's going to happen
this was Kaiser steel a huge integrated
plant like those in Pennsylvania that
mined ore down the street but it went
bankrupt 34 years ago replaced by this
model using imported slabs because the
owners say the Midwest could not or
would not supply a competitor the owners
say they hope the Trump administration
is flexible and not put these steel
workers Brett out of business William
thank you